una medida que no se ha visto en 106
años y que ilustra la gravedad de la
crisis social en Reino Unido por primera
vez en su historia el sindicato de
enfermeros del país decidió ir a huelga
los días 15 y 20 de diciembre después de
que el gobierno se negara a aceptar su
petición de un aumento salarial
llevamos más de una década sin aumento
decente de salario y los enfermeros
trabajan muy duro así que no se trata
solo de aplaudirnos durante la pandemia
creo que debemos respetados y apreciados
por lo que hacemos según las
estimaciones los salarios de los
enfermeros y enfermeras han caído un 20%
desde 2010 en parte debido a la actual
crisis del coste de la vida con una
inflación superior al 11%. el salario
anual de una enfermero principiante
ronda los 27.000 libras unos
32.500 dólares estadounidenses por lo
que uno de cada cuatro hospitales creó
bancos de alimentos para apoyar al pero
el gobierno alega que es un momento
difícil para todos y que no puede
satisfacer las demandas del sindicato
creo que el gobierno tiene que escuchar
de verdad Esto no es algo que las
enfermeras hagan impulsivamente es algo
que el personal de enfermería nunca ha
hecho en todo Reino Unido en tan gran
número Así que significativo y deberían
ver un mensaje muy claro al gobierno de
que tiene que hacer algo
la huelga se produce en un momento en el
que el sistema de salud pública que
lleva años sin financiación suficiente
atraviesa una profunda crisis pero el
descontento no se limita al sector
sanitario muchos otros empleados de los
sectores públicos y privado desde
abogados hasta el personal de los
aeropuertos e incluso los carteros
también han ido a huelga este